I mean I have a pretty complicated
company but I try and understand you
know every aspect of what we do and I
also know very well that if there's some
part I don't understand that's the part
that's gonna get messed up
I mean the one one thing that happens in
a company like mine which is a tech
company is that you know I've also been
pushing for another thing which is
automate everything I can so you know
we've we've got only eight hundred
employees but you know the productivity
that we managed to generate is a vast
multiple of what you would expect from
that number because over the years you
know any process that I've seen where I
can say why do we have 20 people working
on this for six months this is something
that can be automated and well it can
take some effort to automate it but once
it's automated you just crank it out all
the time I'm joined today by Stephen
Wolfram Stephen welcome to the show
thank you I am particularly excited to
speak to you today one of your blog
posts that was released earlier this
year seeking the productive life was
shared around in a number of different
group chats and when that happens when
it appears in a few different spheres of
awareness I think it's usually a pretty
good pretty good idea that it's it's
gonna be something interesting so I
wanted to talk to you today about your
approach to productivity and personal
analytics before we actually get into
what it is that you do the work you do
is is interesting but the way that you
do it is almost this fascinating to me
which is I like to think it's
interesting I've been doing it for four
decades so to better be interesting all
right or I should be embarrassed but yes
but yeah you know the main thing is that
I like to do the things I like to do and
I like to not be distracted by things I
don't need to be distracted by and so I
tend to build all these systems to try
to automate as much as possible to try
to you know be as concentrated as I can
and actually doing the work I want to do
and so I've you know I would say the the
number one tool which is not for
everybody that I've built to get my work
done is I built a company over the last
32 years that has you know eight hundred
people in it then it sort of intended to
be a machine for taking ideas that I
haven't turning them into real things
and so that but one of the things that
is probably more sort of generalizable
is one of the ways that I tend to work
is I'm you know in any given day I'm
trying to create things and trying to
have ideas and I'm trying to turn them
into real things and I tend to follow
the sort of approach of spending a lot
of my time doing what I tend to call
thinking in public which means you know
you're working with a team of people and
some people would imagine that you know
when you're gonna go figure out what to
do you go off on your own you hide away
you figure out what to do this is not
what I tend to do what I tend to do is
it's like I'm doing some meeting
with the people who are involved and
that's the actual time when we figure
out what we're gonna do it's not
something which is happening sort of
behind the scenes and I found that you
know I have been a remote CEO for 29
years now which is another bizarre
feature so most of my you know
interaction with people is screen
sharing + audio I usually avoid video so
like the experience we're having right
now is unusual for me
I'm usually a you know I've got audio
yeah I'm you know sharing the thing that
we're both talking about but I'm seeing
the people it's some and then you know I
I what I like to do is to try and you
know we're trying to figure something
out like today there were several
different meetings that I had about
different kinds of things and we figured
out some things and that's always you
know it's very satisfying and you know
one has to have a you know what I'm
typically doing is I'm typing into one
of our notebook documents and trying to
you know set out what it is we figured
out and so on and then notes get taken
and so on and then it gets turned into
something or something real can happen
from it I understand that's it um you
know I like that it's a I I also tend to
have maybe it's an eccentricity but it's
turned out to be pretty interesting
we've we've publicly live-streamed a lot
of these internal meetings that we've
had so in the last year we probably
livestream 300 hours of these things and
that's a fascinating dynamic because I
originally started doing it just because
I thought these meetings were
interesting they range from very
intellectual stuff to very gritty stuff
about software engineering I just think
these are interesting and you know why
not to have other people be able to sort
of share the fun but it's turned out
we've ended up with you know people join
the the live chat and so on and we get a
lot of sophisticated users of our
products and a lot of other people who
are experts in various kinds of things
and we get real-time feedback which is
pretty interesting so in crowd
crowdsourcing some solutions almost yeah
yeah yeah I mean there there are things
that have actually gone into our
products that was suggested by people in
the live chat and you know it's a very
fast process I mean we could go and we
could say you know okay we you know
world
here's what we're gonna do and a week
later people could respond to it but
actually this is like people are hearing
what's going on real-time typing things
and it's it's it's pretty interesting
and and I think you know to me being
able to do those kinds of figuring
things out sort of live and in public
it makes perhaps egotistically the
things feel a little bit more meaningful
to me I understand you know there's a
process of figuring something out and
you put a lot of effort into it and it's
kind of fun if that effort is actually
archived and I'm not you know I don't
I'm watched any of them
I made them but I know other people have
and you know and I think it's for me you
know part of you know the things I
figured out over the last few decades
about particularly about software design
and language design and so on and this
is my way of kind of helping educate
about those things is you know you can
actually see this happen and you can see
what the process is there's a there's a
term that one of the guys behind the
modern wisdom project Jorge uses when he
talks about evergreen content like that
so this is a discussion that I'm having
with you I've always said I would do
this podcast even if nobody tuned in
because I want to have these discussions
with interesting people however George
describes it as you at scale and I think
that that's a nice way to describe what
it is that you're doing because that
meeting would be going on anyway the
only difference is the difference is the
fact that now other people get to
benefit one of the things that you
touched on right at the beginning there
some of the the listeners may be taken
away on the whirlwind there is wolfram
and and and what what the company does
but one of the things you touched on
that I thought was really interesting
was that you are a remote CEO which
means that you do the vast majority of
you work at home I think you've cited
that you're in the office for hours per
year as opposed to days or weeks for you
but contrasted with that you have this
quite sort of crowd-sourced very
interactive working style I think when
people think about the at home CEO if
you were to say that you kind of think
of this Tony Stark kind of down in the
dungeon on his own tinkering and working
away especially when you then couple
with the fact that a lot of what your
company does in as much as me as a good
avatar for the layperson can understand
is pretty hardcore mathematics and
programming you think down in the
dungeon working on their own it's sort
of and then every so often revealing
something to the rest of the team is
this a quirk of your personality or is
this simply how you found to be the most
optimal way to get stuff done yeah I
mean I've done different things at
different times in my life this is a
really good way to get stuff done
although it probably depends on my
personality that it works I mean so for
example when I was first well after I
started the company for about ten years
I kind of put myself on sort of pseudo
sabbatical working on a basic science
project and that project I did in a
completely reclusive mode I wasn't
talking to anybody
I was just it was me I happened to be in
a high up room rather than down in the
basement but other than that it was
pretty much caged and I'm working on my
own and I was you know I I my schedule
was sort of shifted around so I was
working typically from I would I would
do stuff with a company in the
afternoons and then I would go off and
and start working on my basic science
project sort of I go off and do things
I've during the time when I did the
basic science project I had some kids
and you know I was doing things with the
kids for a while and then I would go and
starting it like eight or nine and
evening work until 6:00 in the morning
doing basic science basically on my own
and it was a you know that was a
definitely a tenacity testing process to
go do that for a decade basically and
you know I got it finished I produced
this book called a new kind of science
which has had all kinds of consequences
in the world but it was you know it was
definitely a pretty intense way to work
so I changed the way I worked after that
and decided that I would try doing this
much more you know with with my internal
group kind of this thinking in public
type mode and it's great now it depends
on the fact that you have people that
you're working with where there's sort
of I don't know whether it's good
chemistry
but where people can know what to expect
um and you know as probably it's
probably I don't know what could
probably figure it out I I should know
the analytics of this from my from my
live streams but I'm guessing there's
probably 150 people who sort of make an
appearance in some livestream or another
that's kind of the out of maybe 800
people in the company so that's probably
the you know that's the set of people
where they kind of are in the right flow
to be able to be involved in these kinds
of live stream type meetings it's it's
interesting that you say that they need
to know what to expect from you and kind
of you do vice-versa if you were I think
a lot of people I've just come off a
podcast with Robert Greene and we're
talking about Inter office politics and
people having to wear masks and all
sorts of things like that most people's
jobs are a combination of the solar
warrior perhaps cubicle work typical
knowledge work emails backwards and
forwards and then some meetings some
collaborative meetings and for the
meetings a lot of people have to play
the role of whatever it is the boss the
subordinate the dis that that that the
other I imagine if you were having to
play a role to 150 people over a
livestream for hours and hours every day
it would be exhausting so I understand
what you mean that you're able to have
sort of brain to mouth to screen with as
little friction as possible and I think
that actually probably quite nicely
leads us on to your approach to
productivity overall because having
donors sophisticated an assessment as I
can of the most sophisticated approach
to productivity that I've seen lack of
friction kind of appears to be one of
the one of the things that it's a
meta-narrative about it so that's right
would you be able to explain your your
approach to your personal infrastructure
yeah well okay so what I mean just to
say one more thing about but what you
were just referring to because I think
it's interesting I mean the the fact is
you know my company is sort of
constructed to be a direct communication
kind of place so you know we've another
feature that makes the remote CEO in
thing less weird or even more weird is
that you know ice
at this example you know nearly 30 years
ago of being a remote CEO so that means
that the majority of people who work at
my company work remotely they all at
home as well or in all kinds of random
places I don't even know where they are
I mean occasionally there'll be some
interesting things somebody will say
well there's a you know there's a
volcano erupting because she's a shark
or something like that yeah right and
it's it's some and then you find out
where they are which I don't typically
pay that much attention to and you know
but I think that's a the fact that one
can develop a company culture where
people are able to actually say what
they think and you know on these live
streams
they're very unvarnished and so people
will be you know saying sometimes people
will get quite passionate about things
and you know that will attack me and
tell me I'm a total idiot and so on and
it's it's some but this is the way that
I like to work because I found you know
it turns out you can have the whole sort
of posturing of that often happens in
many kinds of business settings but it's
like a big waste of time and so long as
reaching the yeah right I mean so so
long as you can handle directness
directness is much more efficient and
and also it helps people I think from a
management point of view you know
knowing where they stand you know if you
say it's good they actually believe you
know it's good and because you'll say
it's bad if it's bad but you know in
terms of my my personal mode of of doing
things I mean you know one thing is the
question of what projects I do because
that's sort of the starting point of how
one is productive I mean I've been lucky
enough that I've basically been able to
build a technology stack for three
decades and much of what I do is
something that will fit into that
technology stack there are things that
you know fortunately it's a broad range
of things it's a broad range of kinds of
different intellectual areas and so on
but when I imagine oh I'll do something
you know completely different I'll I'll
you know write a play or something okay
if I did that I have no idea you know
that would be a big news and I'd have no
idea what to do with it so you know
first step is kind of having a you know
there's a set of things I like to do and
I've sort of built these matrices into
which to put the individual things that
I try to do like you know I try and
build these sort of computational
intelligence systems where I got this
big kind of thing to put that into I
like doing kind of historical writing
about historical biography and things
like that I have another kind of matrix
into which I can put things like that
and I try to avoid doing things which
are kind of which don't fit into any
matrix I have because I know that the
kind of cost of of getting something out
if it isn't in some some sort of matrix
is really high so I you know that's
that's sort of what one step in terms of
the in terms of kind of my my you know
sort of daily life I tend to be a very
you know it's very schedule that has
very it's very kind of structured and
I've built you know all these systems
for sort of prioritizing I you know in a
sense I'm a cheat because I have a whole
company that's that's dealing with
things like prioritizing what I do so
this is not some but you know we've had
to build these systems for I would say
they the number one matter system is I
have all these ideas all the time like
I've had several ideas today which which
will turn into you know which have the
potential to turn into lots of work and
you know the the my the thing I like to
do is to have ideas that actually turn
is something real I've I find it very
frustrating just have ideas and not have
anything happen with them so you know
it's it's a question of how do you build
a system where you can make concrete
those ideas and and then actually kind
of you know have the right project
management and the right kind of flows
to make that happen but you know in
terms of my own you know like I like to
work I I you know the work I do is what
I choose to do and so I like to be doing
that as much as I can so like I also you
know I like to get exercise every day
and so like you know the if I'm you know
I set up a treadmill so that I can have
a you know type on my computer while I'm
walking on the treadmill and that works
fine I also typically do meetings I
usually try to try to get some meetings
that I think are going to be a bit
frustrating scheduled for the time when
I'm on the treadmill because away and
they think that's a signal that Stephen
thought this was going to be a [ __ ]
meeting if there's anyone if anyone if
Stephens executives are listening and
you hear imploding away on the thing
that's because he thought that boring
meeting well it's not so much boy it's
usually frustrating it's usually like
something is going maybe - you need to
get a little bit of energy out yeah yeah
right because it's like like you know
why aren't we managing to do this what's
going on etcetera etcetera etcetera and
then it's like okay I can increase by
half a mile an hour that's a much better
way to manage my my frustration growling
of people if you were if you were a
layperson and you were to think well I'm
the sort of person who likes to work I
want to maximize my ability to do the
work that I like to do not only does it
feel like what I'm gonna guess is close
to your highest calling in life but also
something that's enjoyable as well you
would make it as easy as possible to do
as much of that as possible as higher
velocity as possible with as little
waste and reading through the blog post
which will be linked in the show notes
below for the listeners who want to
check out and I suggest that you do
because it is a it's a real monster but
here's the particular setup that you
have which is like you say these
matrices as you've described them which
are kind of these systems I guess people
would in more sort of common common
terminology where you have a desk which
moves from sitting to standing very
easily at the touch of a button you've
optimized the ergonomics I think I'm
right in saying that you're left-handed
and you've realized that you can you use
a older style roller Mouse right rather
than a turret right usually when I'm at
my desk yes because I found that that's
somewhat faster I mean you know the
point is because I record all those
personal analytics about myself most of
it you know for the last 30 years I've
recorded tons of things
well obviously Lima as I send and
receive and then probably through the
last 20 years I think I've recorded
every keystroke I type and I record kind
of an image of the screen that I've that
I've been in front of me and things like
this and most of the time I don't look
at any of this
right most of the time it just goes it
just yes in a blog posting at the start
of the year right you know and
occasionally I'll look at it but you
know something like is it faster for me
to use a left-handed mouse or trackpad I
can answer that question because just go
look at the data and it takes me you
know probably 15 minutes to go answer
that question because I've got different
computers with different setups and I
just can see how has it compare the two
yeah I think like right in saying that
you've done a third of a million emails
since 1989 and more than a hundred
million strokes no no no much more than
that I've done numb let's see I get a
thing that shows me every month so I've
sent 850,000 emails this blood cells
from 2012 yes right right yes yes yes
you've done half a million of us yes
it's no in fact the the number of emails
that I've that I receive has gone up the
number that I send has gone up it's yeah
I mean that's another you know another
feature of at least my life is you need
to learn to make decisions quickly
otherwise you just go totally bonkers so
you know I'm getting hundreds of emails
every day and you know it's great when
one of them is spam it's pretty rare
that it's spam because that's just a
quick delete um but you know most of the
time their emails that I sort of should
get in some sense and a lot of the time
they're things which are some kind of
decision like do we do this do we do
that whatever and you know one of the
things I've tried to train myself to do
is just make these decisions quickly and
it you know experience helps a lot I
mean one of the challenges in in the
business that I'm in so to speak is what
do you delegate this is what you just do
yourself and you know there's things
where I just know pretty much what to do
it's going to take me ten minutes to do
it
I could delegate it but it's going to
take somebody a week to try and figure
out what to do and there's a chance that
they won't do the right thing and so
what I tend to do my solution to this
is that I'll tend to do this kind of
thinking in public way of you know doing
it I'll say yes I'll do this but you're
gonna watch what I do and so that way
you learn you know how to do it for the
next time yeah and you know that that
works pretty well and it's it's
something also for me you know in in you
know running a software company or
something you might think that the CEO
of a software company of our size would
never like look at the underlying you
know server code or whatever else but
the fact is you know from time to time
it's just easier for me to just look at
it and it also you know the dynamic with
the team for example tends to be you
know you might think oh my gosh that's
totally traumatic to have the CEO go
look at something that some junior
person was supposed to work on and you
know and I suppose sometimes it is
traumatic if something really stupid was
done but that's the rare case it's
usually it was actually hard and the
main thing that is communicated is the
CEO cares about what this junior person
does and isn't totally clueless about
what's involved in doing it and that's a
you know that's a positive message so to
speak and I think this this some you
know this theory that you should I mean
I I tend to delegate whatever I can
delegate that's one of my sort of
principles of of leading a productive
life is delegate what I can delegate but
don't delegate too much and there are
cases where one sort of instinctively
delegates things
I mean I've over the last decade I think
I've learnt more about this you know
their cases where it's like oh this is a
trivial thing this is something about
some you know random Network issue
whatever
let me just delegate that and turns out
that's just a bad idea because given the
experience I have and so on I can solve
it in ten minutes
are there any metrics that you use for
that or is it just experience you said
you just answered it recently yeah it's
just experience and I think you know one
of things that's complicated is because
you know I've been in like the software
business and so on for a disgusting
number of decades now you know I just
know a lot of stuff and it's it's some
you know and it's and I've gotten better
at problem solving and debugging things
and so on over the years and there's not
really a substitute for an extra few
decades of debugging experience
I couldn't I couldn't I couldn't agree
more so to draw a little bit of an
analogy between two industries that I
thought you never thought would it would
be analogous I run club nights so I'm a
club promoter running night clubs late
night industry and stuff like that one
of the things that's interesting myself
and my business partner the 2m DS of
that company and there's a couple of
other partners but there isn't a person
in that company who hasn't started out
as a flier boy at the bottom and it
means that I understand the craft of
every single layer all the way up and
because the company is inherently quite
flat even now at 800 members of staff
for us a lot of the part-time and a lot
of them a lot less technical than yours
but because it's very flat and because
our ascension through it required us to
learn every step of the way and then
model what we did and then distill that
back down to the guys that are below us
if push comes to shove and I get asked a
question about pretty much anything the
likely it is that I've either got a
similar experience or the very
experience that that person's talking
about and I think to any business owners
or entrepreneurs in waiting that are
listening I think earning your craft and
getting the bread and butter of your
actual business understood to a high
high fidelity is a skill that's that
super super useful and when you think
about CEO you think about this
especially remote CEO if you're not the
guy that's in the basement that's
working in tinkering you're the guy that
rocks up in the boardroom like on his
private helicopter once every whatever
for like the AGM that picks up his picks
up his dividend and then goes back to
the Seychelles or something like that I
don't think either of there's not much
romance in in in that person it's cool
it's cool to have a CEO I think
personally to have one it gets stuck in
like you said for me you know my
principle about companies I've told this
to many entrepreneurs is you know on day
one the CEO has to do everything
and gradually you understand more and
more of what the company is doing and
then you can gradually you know hire
people to whom you can delegate those
things but you know I know in the
history of my company everything every
area
that I didn't really understand didn't
get done very well and that's partly
it's for two reasons one because I
wasn't there you know I think it's
partly a question of how the motivation
of people it's like oh the CEO doesn't
care about this we're not going to put
so much effort into it and it's partly
just it's harder for me to kind of
assess it and clean it up and so on so I
think it's a it's a really it's a very
good principle that one should you know
understand you know every aspect of I
mean I have a pretty complicated company
but I try and understand you know every
aspect of what we do and I also know
very well that if there's some part I
don't understand that's the part that's
gonna get messed up I mean the one one
thing that happens in a company like
mine which is a tech company is that you
know I've also been pushing for another
thing which is automate everything I can
so you know we've we've got only eight
hundred employees but you know the
productivity that we managed to generate
is a vast multiple of what you would
expect from that number because over the
years you know any process that I've
seen where I can say why do we have 20
people working on this for six months
this is something that can be automated
and well it can take some effort to
automate it but once it's automated you
just crank it out all the time
scalability right yeah right and it's
it's so I mean that's been look that's
been the story of what we've built you
know as a company that's you know the
products we built and so on help other
people do that too but the you know the
customer number one for these things is
ourselves
yeah and you know I also you know I also
make a point I build a lot of systems
sometimes I build them myself
sometimes our prototype can get other
people to finish them that are for my
own personal sort of productivity of you
know doing all these things if I don't
know like for example I have a simple
system that monitors the history of my
Inbox
you know how many pending emails do I
have how many unread emails and so on
now you might think well that's just a
snapshot you can get by seeing how many
emails you have but for me it's very
useful to see that time flow of to see
you know this week that it's been
growing oh there's this you know then
there's a big cliff because I actually
did a bunch of work you know processing
these things and so on I mean that's a
that's a whole whole other dynamic
went into I did want to get onto your
very special travel clock but before I
get to that this one thing that I
noticed in your in the article that you
talked about you your personal
infrastructure you use a term that says
any flat surface on your desk being a
potential stagnation point for
accumulation and piles of stuff and that
is such a universal truth that anyone
who's listening like look it unless
you're a neat freak look at your desk
and if this space like flat space
there's stuff on it I'm looking at mine
now I'm looking around you in there's
like a set of air pods like a diffuser
that I've not used in months there's
like a coaster like an external hard
drive so your actual physical
infrastructure in terms of the way that
you have your desk set up is to minimize
that as well right yeah right no I have
you know one of my little hacks there is
I have a you know I have a fancy old
wooden desk and I've used for decades
it's some but it has these pull outs
that I had put in at the front so you
know there's the surface of the desk
which really just has keyboard and you
know the monitors and things like that
and I admit it has a pile of books on it
right now which it probably shouldn't
have there's some well the problem with
it you know this is a problem I'm I
happen to be working on some historical
thing I was doing the last couple of
days and the problem with historical you
know research is it tends to involve
physical books and you kind of have to
put them somewhere they're either on the
floor of their own your desk so these
ones are I desk with good news about
these books is once this piece is
finished which it will be in the next
day or so those books will go back and
it's reserved um but you know but what I
do to try and sort of minimize
stagnation desk stagnation so to speak
is I just have these pull outs in front
of the desk and so you know if I need to
actually well eat my lunch or you know
sign a document or or look at a book
actually you know just pull them out at
the front of the desk and do that but I
can't leave them pulled out because then
I couldn't turn it in like that right
and so so it kind of forces me to you
know after I'm done with it you know
clear it off push it back in yes um
so it's a it's a nice it's a little hack
you know you know I've gradually
accumulated a lot of these kind of
little hacks over time I mean another
one that I tend to which you alluded to
is kind of like you know I have a sleep
clock that I it is some it's just a
piece of code well from language code
that just puts up an interface that you
know I press a button that says I'm
going to sleep now it starts a count up
timer that I can see as the time and the
count up timer and it also sends a
message to I actually where does it send
a message to it sends a message to some
system which anyway ends up with the
thing that lets my assistant know kind
of when I went to sleep and then if I'm
in some weird time zone they can kind of
predict I will be up again and you know
so it's just for me to hear that you
have obviously I'm gonna guess compared
with some of the stuff that you guys do
that will be that piece of code will be
like two plus two equals four but the
fact that you're able to create you
think I have this particular
productivity problem in my life I also
have either the personal capacity or the
capacity within my company to fix this
problem it must be a little bit like
being a kid in a playground
sometimes for you while you're like oh
like this is a small problem that I've
encountered and what have we been
talking about so far that when you do
come up against things we model the
issue create a solution and then just
scale and the problem looks after it's
up so I'm gonna guess 20 years ago you
will have gone to bed in some weird time
zone and Mister morning meeting yes yes
and that's this was the fix and now you
know in this fix has been I haven't had
to touch this fiction fix in ages and
that's the yeah I mean that's the you
know I think this is look maybe it's
something that I get from being involved
in the software industry is that there
are bugs in software and one of the
things if you're a software CEO is when
you notice a bug you reported and you
try and get it fixed and I think I'm a
follow sort of the same principle in my
personal productivity and life and so on
yeah you know these things that are
obviously kind of goofy
and like take the time to think about it
see if you can come up with a solution
and then you know execute it if possible
build a system that will keep keep doing
that I mean you know the same thing it's
like I don't know like my computer file
system for example you know I've gone
through I think four generations I think
I worked out maybe it's five I don't
forget in the last 40 years I've gone
through some number of generations of
computer file system and in each case
it's sort of it's optimized for the way
that I'm working at that time and people
people are remarkably bad at organizing
their file systems I discovered I III
even discovered that after I wrote this
post I mean you know I should I should
explain that I'd be mini to write a post
about personal productivity nerdiness
for ages but but I actually the reason I
wrote that post one I did was that we
just we were finishing some big new
version of our of them language product
and my job was done basically because
and it was just a matter of squashing
the last bugs and then the thing would
get shipped out and of course you know
it's supposed to take only a week two
weeks to do that but it was taking a lot
longer and I was like I've got to find
myself something else oh dude right so I
tap out this blog post and when I found
that um you know one of the things that
happens I I'm a reasonably fast writer
and I I really I like writing stuff and
it helps me to think things through to
actually write it
my team has noticed recently that I have
this terrible tendency of converging to
always write 13,000 word blog posts and
they actually have plops which takes in
the fact that it it tends to converge to
that number I'm now that I know that
well one for all of the future ones no
no no it should they should be shorter
they you know what what tends to happen
there it's one of these things where
it's sort of again a personal
optimization you can write shorter or
you know it's actually faster to write a
longer piece sometimes than to write a
shorter one because I'm tend to you know
I write them in one it's just one way
it's a single writing process and it's
not I'm not going back and revising it
and refactoring it and so on and it's
you know for me it's actually I hadn't
really on
stood I maybe five or ten years ago I
started writing a lot of blog post type
things and it's a you know there's a lot
of stuff I think about and I was talking
earlier about these kind of matrices to
put things into you know back in the day
there were things that I was thinking
about but I had no place to kind of you
know no place to put these things like
for example I'm quite interested in
history and philosophy and things like
that and now you know if I get an idea
about one of these things I'll end up
writing some blog post about it and
people will find these blog posts
hopefully interesting or whatever but
there'll be a that something will come
out of the work that I did it's not
something where I'll just say well yes
I'll go do that research and you know
that's all very nice and I enjoy doing
the research but it feels a lot more use
anything upward right yeah I think one
of the things again to try and identify
some of the larger themes that we're
touching on here is that there's a lot
of latent potential if you don't have
the right system to allow whatever it is
that you're doing to emerge because if
you do have the system that was
sufficiently loved friction for you to
write the blog post you know whatever
your for instance whatever your capture
for articles off a tasks offer for brain
dumps and then your review system David
Allen's getting things done or a
two-minute rule or whatever version of
the Wolfram language approach I'm gonna
guess you have if you don't have that
there is so much latent potential just
sitting behind you and I think one of
the things I'm working very hard on at
the moment and listeners will have heard
Thiago Forte's episode which was a guide
to digital productivity touching on many
of the things albeit a slightly lower
degree of sophistication that that you
you do yourself one thing I wanted to
touch on too before we actually get into
the nitty-gritty of wolfram itself you
have a you've mentioned about your
treadmill desk which i think is
fantastic and everyone needs to have a
look at the way that it's set up with
the mouse pad and the resting thing but
you also do a outside laptop ya setup
where you're able to actually get some
vitamin D and get out in the air
absolutely so one of the things already
to ask was
firstly how do you find that affect your
productivity cuz I'm gonna guess that
you'll be tracking that as well and then
secondly overall your motivation to work
that must come and go and that must
actually in itself be difficult to track
it's difficult to track where your
headspace is at and are you able to
explain to the listeners how being out
and about whether that refuse you
whether that actually tends to take away
from your work or how that kind of all
plays in yeah I mean look this whole
question about being you know instantly
on unable to like be productive quickly
over the years or decades I've gotten
incredibly much better at that so for
example I after I spent that ten years
sort of being kind of reclusive and so
on I am you know I would try to set up
meetings but I wouldn't have them like
back-to-back and things like this and I
would find out you know I get into some
meeting about some topic and it will be
like the first ten minutes I'd have to
be telling jokes cuz my brain wasn't you
know wasn't set for the actual topic and
gradually over the years I taught myself
to basically be able to you know I have
meetings scheduled back-to-back and you
know after I finished one I'm going into
the next one I'm looking at the agenda
and then I'm on and I'm able to you know
launch into it now I also know that I
have certain memory decay times so for
example I know if there's some meeting
that has complicated stuff we figured
out and we didn't get it finished I know
I have about three days to get the
follow on and then I have you know
within three days I'll still have the
complete mental state remembered if it's
more than that I'm gonna have to go look
at the notes and things like this to be
able to figure out what was happening
and you know I think that's for me in
terms of productivity the ability to
just go into some meeting and
immediately be yes I you know I'm on I'm
understanding what's going on now you
know in terms of a personal motivation
you know I think by most people's
standards
I'm a very you know even tempered kind
of however you know I consider myself a
procrastinator I think others would
probably not but you know there'll be
things where I would say that I do
rational procrastination to some extent
in the following sense that there are
things like I don't know they'll be let
I'm gonna give a talk somewhere let's
say and there's the question of how long
in advance do I prepare something right
and the answer is I leave it until the
absolutely last minute um and why do I
do that because for example if I'm
giving a talk somewhere and you know the
more I know about the environment in
which I'm giving the talk if I've seen
the audience things like this the more
likely I am to be able to sort of do a
relevant job than if I'm sitting you
know two days earlier trying to prepare
what I'm doing so so there's sort of
forms of procrastination like that that
I tend to and I you know sometimes I
will break my own rule and end up
preparing something further in advance
or another in other cases is product
releases and the question is you working
very hard to do a product release and
it's like when do you write the
marketing materials for the product
release now sometimes sometimes I like
to write them before we even start
building the product because then I know
what you know why anybody would be
expected to care about this but often
it's like you have to wait until the
thing is done basically because
otherwise you you just you know there's
you can waste a lot of cycles you know
inventing things which oh well actually
it turns out once you've done it you
understood something different and so on
but I think in terms of this some you
know personal motivation look them the
the number one the zeroeth feature of my
personal motivation is the things I do
are things I really like to do now you
know when you build I do big projects
you know I do projects that last decades
and you know that is not the case that
every micro piece inside every project
is as fascinating as every other one but
but somehow you know I find the you know
I can sort of I manage to average that
out you know I think different people
are tend to be at different times in
their lives actually optimized for
different lengths of projects like I
find you know that company for example
you know they're people who are like
optimized for the 15 minute project and
those people you know if they're in
technical support for example it's
fantastic they'll you know they'll come
in Somis you will come in they'll solve
it in 15 minutes everybody will be happy
on they go and there are other people
who are optimized for you know the three
months
project and if you feed the three-month
project person the 15 minute project
they'll spend the first week you know
preparing the structure that they need
through the project and it's all a big
design you couldn't you could have done
it halfway before lunch so I mean I
think you know I I it's one of these
things where you know you have to be
picking projects which are sort of
optimized for your you know I mean I
wouldn't claim that every single thing
that I do every single day like this
morning I was working on some stuff that
it was like and it's kind of you know I
it's not I don't consider it the most
thrilling but yet you know the end kind
of justifies the effort spent on it and
I find that you know almost anything
done sufficiently well is interesting
and you know people are always saying oh
this is such a boring area I can't you
know I can't study then then whether
it's in science or in technology
development you know this is just so
boring and it's like no if you actually
try and think about it and you try and
really understand what's going on it
will be interesting and you know that's
that's also a piece of self motivation
that that I use because it's what my
experience has been and you know
sometimes when you do things when you
think oh this is kind of boring I'm just
gonna skate over the top of it um then
it is boring yeah but when you actually
dive in and really try to understand
what's going on turns out it's actually
pretty interesting and pretty
intellectually challenging or or
whatever else yeah but in terms of in
terms of walking outside you know I I am
my wife had been saying for probably 20
years that you know it was a good
walking outside was it outside was a
good thing I was like I ignore that you
know it doesn't it's who cares yeah but
I finally realized through some
analytics that I did to be fair of
course of course that it was but it was
having her that when I happened that I
was you know spending time outside it
happened that my resting heart rate was
lower and that was a good sign that that
was worthwhile and I found you know I
there was the challenge I had been
thinking about this for like 20 years
how can I be just walking around and you
know typing on a on a computer and I
thought back oh sometime the 90s I was
thinking oh I'd use augmented reality
see and I was trying to figure out how I
could use a one-handed cord keyboard
type thing and so I had all kinds of
fancy stuff yeah and the technology
wasn't really there for that and then it
was about some a little bit more than a
year ago I was some had some very some
fancy tech event and actually an event
the the scenario was just really kind of
funny it was an event that put on by
Jeff Bezos and he was he had a photo op
that involved him walking with this
robotic dog okay so I was some so I
happened to be right right there you
know I think I've just been talking to
him and there was you know there he was
with a photo op and the robotic dog and
there are a lot of girl wasn't that
exciting but what was really interesting
to me was there was a guy just outside
the frame for the photo op who had this
walking desk and a laptop who was
controlling the robotic dog and that was
that for me was the the him you know
that was the winning piece of technology
in the picture but so I hadn't really
internalized this idea that you could
really have a walking desk we just put a
laptop on a thing with a bunch of straps
that look like you know somebody who's
selling popcorn or something yeah yeah
and um and you could actually type on
this and I you know I should have
realized this 20 years earlier because
that's really it's a trivial solution
it's you know I was know it's a baby
aisle area it's a baby carrier turned
round yes with a laptop right it's the
it's similar to the story which actually
a audience member I use this in a
podcast a couple of weeks ago and one of
the listeners messaged me and said that
it's wrong but it's the only useful
example that I've got and it's when the
Americans were to try and develop a
space pen that would write upside down
in zero gravity and the Russians just
use a pencil it's like one of those
things where you think sometimes the
simplest solution I find it so hilarious
to think about you around Jeff Bezos and
this robotic dog which is obviously
supposed to be like the focus the focal
point of attention and you've been like
excuse me just move the dog out of the
way excuse me mate just remind me what
that strap around your necks made off
please it's carrying your I think you
know in in the photo op it looks like an
autonomous dog but the most interesting
thing was the guy controlling it I mean
it was it was you know it turns out
turns out to my surprise it's perfectly
straightforward to type on a you know if
you've got this thing in front of you
stay I didn't know it will be
straightforward to do that um now you
know what I found is I kind of have a
hierarchy in if I'm writing something
which is really all about writing and
I'm really trying to type the maximum
number of words per per minute so to
speak then sitting at my desk is or
standing at my desk is going to be the
oil is always going to be the winner
you know treadmill is a little bit less
effective in terms of you know how fast
I can type for long period I'm walking
outside is again a little bit less
effective but I you know the typical
scenario for me when I'm walking outside
I'm usually using screen sharing on and
I'm in some meeting and I'll be typing a
certain amount of stuff but I won't be
it's not like when I'm writing some
football and when I'm just purely typing
and I find I mean you know what I tend
to find is when I'm if I'm really in
gear writing a blog post then I can do
it when I'm walking on a treadmill and
even sometimes when I'm outside but when
I'm kind of still just getting warmed up
and I haven't quite you know got into
the into the swing of it then I have to
be sitting at my desk or it doesn't
really I am cognitive effort to do that
I mean just avoiding walking into things
I'm gonna guess you must have to curate
the route that you actually walk to and
so before we move on to I'm a conscious
of time and I know you're a very busy
man before we move on to a couple of
cool things that I want to do with
Wolfram Alpha and an explanation about
Mathematica as well final question I
like to ask about your productivity do
you think that there's much more left in
the system for you like do you think
that there's more that you can squeeze
out of the lemon of sort of your life in
your daily routine at the moment or do
you think you wouldn't like a capacity
that's an interesting question I mean I
think hmm you know well it's interesting
because I think about what the next
project I want to do are and I'm
actually a little frustrated because
there are a couple of really big
projects so I mean one thing to do for
like 10 years or more and I really want
to get the time to do them and so for me
it's important to figure out
I you know squeeze the other stuff to
the point where I can get these done and
one of the challenges sort of a lifetime
challenge is how do you end up doing new
stuff because you know something like me
I built a bunch of cysts you know things
I you know got people who depend on the
things I do it's like we've got a lot of
there's a lot of stuff that's just
flowing forwards and so I think one of
the one of the sort of personal
challenges in the the attitude
challenges is can one do new stuff in
the light of that because it's very easy
to say well I've got all this stuff I
could spend all my time just you know
maintaining and turning the crank on
things I've already built and things you
know things I've already done sort of
products we built etcetera etcetera
etcetera but for whatever reason I find
it you know I kind of have a great urge
to go do new stuff as well and you have
to be just a little bit irresponsible to
be able to do that you have to decide
you know I'm not going to put a hundred
percent time into this thing I'm going
to try and push it squash it a little
bit so that I have time left over to go
do new things so it's a it's some yeah I
mean it's interesting question I mean I
I think that there are probably you know
what one questions into two pieces one
is are the things that I'm doing that I
shouldn't be doing and the other is the
things that I am doing can I do the more
efficiently and I'm good way to frame it
right and so you know the and you know
in the things I'm doing that I shouldn't
be doing it's you know that that's
complicated thing because you know you
say okay there's some meeting that I'll
be doing that's reviewing something or
other okay I can like not do that and
then there is a decent chance that that
project will keep running okay but there
is also a certain chance that it will go
off the rails and so that's a you know
so you have to kind of try and figure
out and and some actually I did a big
refactoring recently of project review
meetings of figuring out you know how to
aggregate different pieces so that it's
one meeting that's an hour every week or
two that used to be three differently
and so on so I mean there's this some
but in terms of the yeah so I I it's a
good question I have to think about that
question I don't you know if I knew
to be honest I'm I'm unembarrassed and
answering this question in the following
sense that if I could say to you
immediately oh there's this obvious
inefficiency I would be a bit
embarrassed because though um you know
it's so I started already
yeah right but so that's some but so you
know yeah right I I mean there's there's
some makaan to new big projects and they
will have a slightly different rhythm
than projects I have previously done and
so they will have their own kind of it
will take you know I I know that when I
work on when I start doing some
different kind of project there's a
certain amount of turbulence at the
beginning as things aren't well
understood and you know gradually I
understand what the systems are and get
into the swing of it and then it then it
can flow nicely I have to save for
someone who works in what to most people
would feel like a very transactional
well controlled hermetically sealed
environment that is cold and maths the
way that you speak about the overall
philosophy is a lot more the way that an
artist or a musician would speak about
it that to do with the sensations and
the understanding the experience based a
conception of what is going to happen
which is emerging from all of this past
experience that you've had I think
there's a lot to be said as we've
touched on already that just spending
time and attention as you'd refer to it
in the gym of just getting to grips with
the bread and butter and then beginning
to slowly add more and more on and
expand that domain of competences is
something that's very useful for a lot
of people so final thing Wolfram Alpha
is an answer engine not a search engine
would you be able to UX would you be
able to explain to the listeners who
don't understand what an answer engine
is what what that means please well we
usually like to use the term
computational knowledge engine that's
our fancier term for it you know what it
is
thing where you ask it a question in
natural language and it will try and
compute the answer to that question so
you might ask it I don't know and you
know you can use it it provides
computational knowledge for Sirian for
Alexis oh yeah it's the basis it's the
basis of Syrian Alexa right well the
compass and knowledge components yes yes
so it's it's the thing that's answering
it's not the thing that's saying play
this song it's thing that's answering
the question you know what's the
population of such-and-such a place or
you know if you type in a good party
trick with off now fer is type in a
first name and it'll give you the the
mostly US state or there has some other
countries as well it'll give you the
number of people with that name who've
been born every year in the last hundred
years okay so but then what it has to do
because it's actually computing things
is it knows the mortality curves for
four people and so it can figure out you
know what is the distribution of people
alive today who have you know first
named Chris for example yeah right so
then a good party trick is you type in
somebody's name and we'll give this
distribution it'll say most common age
of a person with that name and just
because of the way statistics works
there's a pretty good chance that the
person you're talking to has that name
yeah is a stage yeah so that's a that's
some that's for 30 I mean so you know
and what we're doing and Wolfram Alpha
is we've been for the last few decades
we've been accumulating kind of
knowledge about the world in computable
form so you know you can say where's the
International Space Station okay so
that's something you actually have to
compute you can't just there's not just
because it moves all the time and you
have to be working out you know what its
orbit is and so on and then computing
the answers of that question so what we
are what we really the the thing we've
done is is mostly translating human
natural language the kinds of questions
people ask into a computational language
and then using the knowledge that we
built up in our knowledge base to be
able to answer those questions I mean
kind of the goal in the end is there's a
bunch of systematic knowledge that our
civilization has has built up you know
my goal which to be fair I've had since
I was probably about 12 years old is
kind of to accumulate that knowledge in
computational form and have it be the
case that any question that can be
answered on the basis of knowledge
that's known in our civilization we
should be able to automate answering
that question that's kind of the goal
and I know we've been able to do that in
more and more domains and that's some so
that that's that's the story of wolf now
and you know I use it like oh I'll use
it probably today I'll go type in
sunburn and it'll tell me because it
knows where I am and it knows the UV
index data and so on and it knows you
know I can look up for my skin type
it'll tell me you know it's whatever it
is 35 minutes to to sunburn and if I
don't put on sunscreen or a hat or
whatever else yeah
and that's I actually I've been doing QA
of that particular function now for
probably eight or nine years and I can
say that the only times I've gotten
sunburned of the times when I thought I
was smarter than it was oh it's the same
as when you try and go you don't listen
to Google Maps and you think no no this
way homes always quicker and it knows
that there's the traffic the traffic jam
there and sure enough you sat in the
traffic kicking yourself for not
listening to Google Maps earlier on so
yet to any of the listeners who want to
go and play some of these games
WolframAlpha at Wolfram Alpha calm and
just type in where is the International
Space Station or typing someone's first
name are there any other cool things
before we go there gosh they're like
lots of lots of things I mean there lots
of kind of people always enjoy these
Estimate type things of you know how
many you know how many soccer balls fit
in a 747 or something these kinds of
things or one that I was trying to
figure out actually took two steps to do
this was we took all the water and all
the oceans on earth and you rolled it
all up into a ball how big would that
ball be and it's which is relevant
because I was trying to understand
something about the origin of water on
the earth I mean this is you know the I
mean just to fill in for a second the
the main sort of intellectual thread of
what what I've tried to do for a long
time is this thing we call often
language which is an attempt to make
kind of a full-scale computational
language which means you know you have
programming languages where you're kind
of telling step
time you're telling a computer what to
do the goal of sort of our kind of
computational language effort is to have
a language to represent things in the
world computationally so in a in a
standard programming language you might
have something that says this is the
value of variable something like this
but in in our language and it's sort of
full computational language you know the
town of Newcastle is an entity and you
can compute things about it so I can say
what's the Geo distance from Newcastle
to Boston or something so it's being
able to have a language for expressing
things in the world in a way that you
can compute from them and that's some I
mean I think it's a I've been working on
this now well kind of for 40 years
actually altogether but that term I I've
only I steadily understand you know that
this is an important thing because well
it's it's the thing that people use the
they use our products in well lots of
R&D and education kinds of settings our
products are really widely used to to
figure out new you know to figure out
new things but but there are what's some
what's interesting about this process so
just to tell a sort of historical tale
you know there was a time when people
like 400 years ago or so people were
doing math and they did math by writing
everything out in words so there wasn't
a plus sign there wasn't a time sign
that was only invented four hundred
years ago yeah and so once that had been
invented then things like algebra got
invented and calculus got invented and
so on but while he was still kind of
writing out all your math and words that
was very hard to invent there wasn't a
good way to kind of Express mathematical
ideas in a kind of language that was
convenient for people well we're in the
same situation with computational ideas
and that's kind of what we've been
trying to solve is to create a
computational language that allows one
to sort of express computational ideas
in a way that both computers can read
and humans can read and this has been a
pretty successful thing and we're kind
of seeing you know all these different
fields you can call you know
computational X where X is you know
archeology zoology whatever else
all these fields they need kind of a a
computational language to express the
computational ideas that come up in
these fields and that's kind of what I
built I think the it you've touched on
something there which the listeners may
be thinking sounds a little bit esoteric
but when you actually think about it the
fact that the democratization of
knowledge as it is kind of in the way
that Wikipedia I suppose works in you
want to find something out and then
Wikipedia gives it back to you but the
thing that you want to find out has to
be searched for in an incredibly
specific way in the right language for
the correct thing that is you want it to
do and it will feed out a very narrow
range of results based on what it is
that you want but obviously with Wolfram
language taking natural language
converting that into computer code that
then feeds back out something legible by
a human who has no no training no
special understanding of this and then
gives them the answer that they wanted
or potentially an answer that they
didn't even know that they wanted but is
the one that they wanted alone and then
I think am i right in saying that you're
looking to even step this up even
further and allow laypeople to create
computer programs
I want a program that will do this show
me yeah you want to then be able to
create natural language to compute a
program to understand it to then create
a computer program to then do what the
person wanted well here's the issue the
issue is that natural language is really
good if you have a quick question you're
asking if you're trying to say let me
define how this really complicated thing
works that's not something where natural
language is not particularly good at
that
that's where computational language is
really good the trick is to have people
be able to think in this computational
language and that's what happened you
know when mathematical notation was
invented and so on people started being
able to think in mathematical notation
they started being able to to actually
you know think through the math that
everybody's taught these days you know
after four hundred years everybody gets
taught this stuff probably too many
people get taught some aspects of it but
you know when it comes to computational
language you know we're just at the very
beginning of people learn
this and learning it you know early in
their lives and you know when they're 10
or 11 years old or whatever and you know
once they learn it then they get to take
the sort of computational thinking that
they might be doing and put it in some
concrete form that both they can read
and a computer can also go execute and
that's a you know for you know from a
sort of big picture point of view in a
sense what one is doing by creating what
I've been trying to do in creating this
computational language it's giving
people a language in which to think
computationally which also happens to be
a language that computers can execute
but it's one of the really important
things I think is that it provides a way
to kind of formulate your thoughts
computationally and that's something you
know when we talk about making you know
personal productivity and so on a lot of
I suspect I can't necessarily trace all
they're all the connections but a lot of
what I end up doing in trying to sort of
formulate how I want to set up systems
and so on
is informed by the fact that you know
I've spent a large part of my life sort
of inventing this computational language
to try and take sort of general thinking
about things and make it computational
and once you've made it computational
you have it in a sort of more
streamlined concrete form so that for
example you can automate it and get a
computer to do it and that's kind of the
that that's you know that's a big piece
of sort of the the intellectual effort
and I suspect that you know when it
comes to I don't know making the sleep
time o'clock or something there are you
know yes that's very easy to do in the
in the language that we have and you
know it um and it's also but it's also
something we're probably certain aspects
I you know it's always a little bit hard
to introspect and understand this but
certain aspects of how that works are
probably because I thought about it in
sort of a computational way of this is
how it you know this is how to structure
it and it's not just like oh well I'd
like to know kind of when I you know how
long was you know how long I've been
asleep type thing it's kind of there's a
little probably a little bit more to it
which is a little bit hard to introspect
and see through but I think that's the
design of motive of
thinking that you have internalized that
is your work which sounds really weak
sigh as a lay person again I don't I
don't code I don't understand how it
code but I would have thought that the
transfer from screen to real world would
have been really limited but what it
actually appears is that you want to
define things as clearly as possible
have a number of variables that you can
control and then have as little friction
and then bugs in the system and then
you've created a lifestyle of
productivity a work cadence out of that
and all of these other solutions see I I
would think so one is that one of the
directions is creating computational
contracts so people are you know
blockchain people talk about spark
contracts and so on so the generalized
version of that is computational
contracts that is you know I'm sure in
your work life
it's full of contracts of one kind or
another and those contracts are written
down in legalese they're written in sort
of a version of English that is a little
bit closer to code because you're trying
to be a little bit precise about you
know this is what we mean exactly
etc but um you know what what we will
achieve with this sort of computational
language direction you will be able to
write contracts in code and that means
that the the importance of that is you
know sometimes the contract says they're
currently done you know you actually
want some wiggle room in some place or
other but you know when when contracts
are being executed automatically by
machines and things it's it's really you
can't really do that and that's where
you know if you can express sort of a
human what you want to have happen and
you can express it in computational
language turn it into a computational
contract have it automatically
executable then that's that's an
interesting thing that that makes make
sure you know you've talked about
friction that's a that's a great
friction reducer is to be able to say no
it doesn't need a person in the middle
of you know saying this is how this
should work yeah it's just automatic you
know it's it's you have some contract
that says I don't know what you know
based on the number of the you know if
you're promoting something maybe you
know you have some PR firm or something
based on the number of media mentions
they'll get you know some you know
commissioned some such other thing and
but then what does that mean
computationally well that means
computationally you have a program that
says it's gonna go search the web it's
going to have these criteria for
deciding if it's a mention of this thing
and then there's just going to be some
formula in there and maybe it's going to
use some machine learning classifier to
decide if it was a positive sentiment
mention or a negative sentiment mention
but in the end of it it's just a piece
of code and nobody gets to you know
nobody has to go figure anything else
it's just you know the code runs
somebody gets paid you know a hundred
dollars or something or they don't and
it kind of makes the world a you know a
more efficient place it's gonna be
solicitors everywhere all over the globe
just tearing their hair out at the
sounds of this is even your tariff but
you're terrifying everybody in law at
the moment here you know what it is
it's gonna be the other way it's like
the paperless office right when
everybody said the paperless office it's
gonna be you know nobody's gonna have
anything printed out and so on at least
for a while at least for a few decades
there was a lot more paper around
because what will happen in this case
with computational contracts is there'll
be a lot more contracts in the world and
because there'll be a lot of things
where there was no point in having you
know right now is too much friction to
have a contract but you know it's like
you know many things that people do
there'll be a little contract that says
and things will happen automatically
based on that or whatever else and you
know a lot of the I mean I know from
because we've interacted with a lot of
law firms and so on that you know that
the sort of big more sophisticated ones
are like we want to get involved in this
we want to be writing computational
contracts and we want to be the ones
creating the intellectual property that
is all those weird clauses that get
added you know that's like well you know
we'll sell you all these clauses that
will take care of you know what happens
if it rains when you're doing some
events I'll say yeah of course because
you're going to have to have someone who
understands the law to interpret it into
the programming language and that
particular in the same way as I want to
make I want to process a document I need
a word processing piece of software you
also require this recipe almost yeah
yeah right that's the anyway this is the
this is the kind of thing I think about
for a living so to speak and you know
the these these questions about personal
productivity are the are the way that I
manage to get to think about stuff like
that and and maybe you know one of the
things that I've learnt cuz I've been
interested in you know mentioned
personal analytics and so on and I I've
tended to store sort of everything right
I've done and then the real question is
can you put together your personal
history because there's you know I've
got you know millions of emails and so
on it's like what is the arc of history
that that corresponds to so to speak in
other words you can look at each
individual one and I wouldn't say it's a
project of mine actually right now is to
try and make more automation to finding
these kinds of arcs of history from
individual documents and so on but the
thing that is always interesting for me
to understand I think it's something
that is is it an interesting
introspection for people is when you've
done something can you figure out how
you actually got to be able to do that
thing and so for example a lot of the
stuff that I end up doing with it ends
up being not the typical thing that
everybody else does you know there's
there's usually some whole chain of
things and for example this whole you
know spending a lot of my life
developing this computational language
is probably the reason that I end up
getting to do a bunch of personal
productivity things and I haven't quite
joined it was dot sometimes doing this
history and understanding like like for
example the Wolfram Alpha project I had
thought about doing that project when I
was a kid I thought this project is too
hard and I thought among other things to
be able to sort of you know ingest
knowledge about the world and so on and
be able to answer questions you're gonna
need a complete AI you're gonna need a
brain like thing and so that was you
know I came back to it every so often
but I kept on saying making a brain like
things really hard then I did a bunch of
basic science that I won't term in the
bits has all kinds of applications but
there's a there's a thing called the
principle of computational equivalence
that comes out from that and one of the
implications of that is you know it's a
piece of basic science and sort of
philosophy of science but one of the
implications is there's no kind of
bright line between intelligence and
mere computation and so that sort of
philosophical point made me realize gosh
if
I'm taking that seriously then this
thing that I now call wolf alpha that
I've sort of wondered could it be built
well if I take my own theory seriously
then yes it could be built and so so
then I started building it but it took
you know in a sense a very circuitous
route because it takes understanding
this quite philosophical thing to
realize that yes actually you know if I
know what I'm talking about about that
philosophical thing then it's some you
know then then I should be able to build
this practical thing and again it needs
to it needs to at least be able to
existing concept before it can exist in
reality right most things get
constrained by reality people's dreams
tend to be bigger than their achievement
and the same thing goes for for most
stuff but yeah if you can if you've got
the backup that you as you've alluded to
there and I will link to some of the
blog posts which have been illuminating
to me which of the listeners who want to
find out a little bit more about your
philosophy on that but Steve I'm aware
that you are an incredibly busy man and
I do want to let you guess before you
see we've got you in trouble and EDD
there's gonna be emails pinging all over
and your assistants get it'll have been
automated at least yes the husband I
think I've been getting chippings and I
know I'm supposed to start a live
streamed designer review meeting so so
you go see the beginning of that we'll
be late but amazing final thing where
can people find you online if they want
to find out more stephen wolfram calm
there we go that's all that we meet
Stephen thank you so much for your time
I really appreciate it
no interesting stuff thanks a lot
[Music]
you